this is silver in iceland where i got to
swim between two continental plates on
one side of me is the north american
plate on the other side
is the eurasian plate and here this is
where they're very
slowly tearing apart every word i said
there was technically
true and i don't want this video to take
away from the magic
swimming in silver was incredible my
guides were great
i'd recommend it but here's the thing
this is the bridge between continents
it's about a hundred kilometers
southwest of there
and it also claims to be the point where
the two
continental plates are breaking apart
and the two cracks this and sulfur
they aren't connected not to each other
and not to the countless other cracks
like them across iceland now the last
time i did a video like this
a few people got angry at me because
yes i'm about to debunk something and if
you have fond memories of
diving or snorkeling between continents
or holding up this bridge in a photo
this might make it a little less magical
particularly if you're able to dive deep
enough at silver
to get the photo where you touch both
sides at the same time
you need to be a qualified diver to head
down to the depths
i'm not so i'm staying up there on the
surface with a snorkel and
yes my camera lens keeps fogging up i
tried to do a piece of camera while i
was in the water
but it didn't go well if you're
qualified
here's what's true sulfur is a crack in
the earth and it is between two tectonic
plates
absolutely if you're diving there you
are 100
diving in between the continents the bit
that
doesn't hold up is that's not the
dividing line
you've not got a different tectonic
plate on each side of you
you're just in the bit where they split
apart a good way of thinking about it is
imagine that this bridge really was
between the continental plates imagine
that
that really was the north american plate
and this really was
the eurasian plate what would this be
down below
i mean other than a lot of volcanic sand
that's getting in my shoes
is it neither both a bit in between
whatever this is it's true for this
whole
area for kilometers you can see that on
the map near the bridge
this is just one of many places where
the rocks happen to be a little bit
weaker
so this is where they broke into to let
the whole area
stretch plate tectonics is messy and
three-dimensional
this is just where it looks dramatic as
you move out of this area east or west
over kilometers the cracks become fewer
and fewer and less and less common
and then they stop and you can
definitely say that you're on
one of the continental plates but this
bridge is symbolic
sulfur is symbolic it's where one of the
cracks happened to breach an underground
river
but swimming in silver is still an
incredible experience
and here's why silfra is filled with
glacial melt water an underground river
surfacing there the water has been
filtered for decades through rock
and there's so much of it that there's a
constant current pushing any impurities
out into the nearby lake
which includes me i'm swimming in a
literal river of mineral water and the
visibility is perfect
in other parts of iceland water like
that is bottled and sold but
here we're inside things national park
which was the home of the icelandic
parliament for eight centuries
and is the most historic part of the
entire country
so no bottling plants there and because
it's glacial melt water
it's also only just above freezing point
about two or three degrees celsius
so i need to wear a dry suit to prevent
hypothermia
swimming in sulfur is technically
swimming between the continents that is
true and if there's been one theme
through my videos over the years it's
been that the real world does not fit
into the neat little boxes that we'd
like it to even though we keep designing
systems
that have strict categories and sharp
dividing lines
there are always exceptions the
continents don't split
at a single line the real world is far
more messy than we often think
you